those of you who are a fan of mods and
making your PC games look fantastic will
probably be pleased to hear that the
popular icenhancer mod will be making
its way to GTA 5 for those who don't
know icenhancer is probably the most
frequently used graphics overhaul mod
for GTA 4 and current versions of the
mod for that game look even better than
vanilla GTA 5 creator of the mod Hissam
Kolani has come out this weekend to say
that the mod will also supports grand
theft auto 5 if you want to get a feel
for it there's a 10 minute video you can
check out on gamespot so far the modders
in its early stages but development so
far include removing the blur effect on
the background producing fog enhancing
water textures and letting you change
the intensity of the Sun among other
things let me know down in the comments
if you can spot the difference and how
much you care about graphical
improvements we'll keep you updated on
GTA and everything else gaming on
gamespot so be sure to stay tuned